puma ist eines der fünf größten
flüchtlingscamp der welt etwa 160.000
menschen leben hier viele sind in
zweiter oder sogar schon dritter
generation hier geboren und die meisten
von ihnen haben wenig hoffnungen wieder
in ihre heimatländer zurückzukehren
einer von ihnen ist denn adria cure
seine familie kommt aus dem südsudan der
28 jährige aber ist schon hier in kuba
geboren er kennt nichts anderes denken
zeigt uns seine hütte ein winziger raum
ein paar habseligkeiten ein bett mehr
besitzt er nicht nebenan wohnt seine
mutter gegenüber seine ältere schwester
agnes ihr aller leben spielt sich in
zwei hütten ab als heimatlose in einem
land in dem sie nicht erwünscht sind
viel besser ich habe manchmal das gefühl
dass man schikaniert wird dass jemand
sagt du gehörst nicht zu dieser
gemeinschaft du bleibst nur hier in
kalkutta für diese jahre ich bete zu
gott dass ich vielleicht irgendwann aus
diesem lager wegziehen kann kam denn
nimmt mich mit in eine schule in der er
als eine art hilfslehrer arbeitet eine
kleine perspektive
° sprechen die 150 mädchen in seiner
klasse nach was denken ihnen vorgibt
kinder deren familien eines verbindet
sie sind geflohen aus dem südsudan
burundi ruanda dem kongo hier sitzen sie
friedlich nebeneinander und träumen alle
von einer besseren zukunft
ist perfekt ich denke es ist perfekt
vierter zu werden jemand kann piloten
oder ärztin werden aber ich möchte
piloten werden
ich möchte so gerne ärztin werden weil
ich gerne menschenleben retten und
anderen zeigen möchte wie man das macht
wie aber so frage ich mich sollen diese
kinder eine chance haben auf eine
wirkliche zukunft wenn sie schon so hart
kämpfen müssen um das tägliche essen das
die vereinten nationen ausgibt das leben
hier ist hart erst recht für die
jüngsten nur wenige kilometer von kabul
entfernt inmitten des albernen ort
kenias liegt ein nächstes
flüchtlingscamp carlo bay auch hier
leben 70.000 menschen aus allen
krisenregionen ostafrikas zusammen
unterschiedliche religionen kulturen
traditionen
carlo bay ist eine art pilotprojekt des
un flüchtlingshilfswerks hier arbeiten
einheimische und flüchtlinge zusammen
die bergrheinfelder und betreiben kleine
geschäfte so hofft man auf eine bessere
integration und carlo bay könnte zu
einer art vorbild für flüchtlingscamps
auf der ganzen welt werden in dieser
gärtnerei arbeiten 300 fahrer und
fahrerinnen die meisten sind geflüchtet
aus ihrer heimat doch es gibt auch
menschen aus der region die hier
pflanzen wie in einem
gemeinschaftsgarten beackert jeder und
jede eine eigene parzelle
hier treffe ich ki.ka ghani die 41
jährige kam vor sechs jahren mit ihrer
familie aus dem kongo jeden tag schuftet
sie auf ihrem kleinen feldbau tomaten an
und verkauft sie für 75 cent das kilo
wenn sie denn ernten kann so kann
architekt und wir haben ein problem mit
schädlingen sie sind wirklich
problematisch
die sengende sonne und vor allem der
mangel an wasser
auch heute müssen sie bei über 40 grad
das wasser von weit her tragen viele
felder sind verdorrt ein bohrloch wäre
gut um wasser zu speichern doch wie
sollen sie das bezahlen bei gerade
einmal 13 euro pro flüchtling pro monat
die das un flüchtlingshilfswerk zahlt
häufig adra niemals findet man eine frau
wie mich mit ihrem kind das nach essen
schreit aber die nichts hat um das kind
zu füttern und ich würde alles tun damit
ich kein anderes kind hungern sie
wir fahren noch einmal zurück nach kuba
in der untergehenden sonne spielen
jugendliche fußball es wirkt fast
idyllisch viele kennen die heimat ihrer
familie nicht werden sie wegen
anhaltender konflikte vielleicht nie
kennenlernen die kinder die vor der
hütte von lehrer denkt schachspielen
sind hier geboren und trotzdem werden
sie nie eine kenianische
staatsbürgerschaft erhalten ihnen bleibt
nur der traum von einem besseren leben
so wie auch denn
das bisschen geld das ich hier bekomme
sind gerade mal 50 dollar aber ich
brauche einen ort an dem ich mehr habe
auch um meine eigene organisation zu
gründen damit ich anderen helfen kann
ein leben in frieden das ist wovon sie
träumen und nicht mehr gefangen zu sein
im flüchtlingscamp von kummer